[Music]
Two bottles: one's liquid, one's solid.
The question is, if they roll each
on this rod - on the inside - which--
[Thump]
[Destin laughs]
I just want to make my video, alright?
[Laughs]
Really.
Okay, here's the question:
Ice, is it gonna make it first; or
water, is it gonna make it first?
Over here, you've got rotational inertia of
all the mass of the fluid to worry about.
Over here you've got losses due to
fluids here you've gotta worry about.
The water's actually going to heat up.
Pick now, on these two boxes, and if you
get it wrong you have to subscribe.
Okay, you ready? 3... 2... 1...
[Music]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.